big news tonight from the las vegas
raiders as president mark bodaine turns
in his resignation thank you for joining
us at six i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise feldes this is really
huge news for our team joining us now in
studio is sports director chris matthews
with the latest chris
well thank you guys yeah here's news
that just broke with the last hour and a
half and it's stunning news for all
those close to the organization
and those who followed the raiders to
las vegas that entire story raiders
announcing that
president mark bedane is stepping down
he's been with the organization over 30
years he started at the bottom and
worked his way
all the way to the top becoming
president of the multi-billion dollar
franchise
he was the person who helped drive that
move from oakland to las vegas
raiders owner mark davis telling us in a
statement
today i have accepted mark bedane's
resignation as president of the las
vegas raiders
mark has been an integral part of the
raider family for 30 years
rising from a training camp driver to
president of the entire
organization his efforts in helping to
build the most magnificent stadium in
the sports and entertainment capital of
the world
will never be forgotten i wish mark his
wife amy daughter ali and sons bernie
and zach all the best
in whatever the future holds once a
raider always a raider
the successful construction operation of
legion stadium has been
unequivocally the most challenging part
of my 30 years with the organization
says mark bedan
seeing it through to the end has been
rewarding beyond measure
together the raiders in las vegas
accomplished what seemed
impossible now that the project is
complete it is time for me to focus on
my family and look ahead to new pursuits
i am forever grateful to md who is mark
davis for his unwavering support and
friendship
i wish him and the raider family the
best i will always feel part of the team
because
everyone knows once a raider always a
raider
well the raiders owner telling us that
dan ventrelli will take over
as they find a replacement for bodaine
coming up in sports there is something
that
mark madane wishes he had gotten
accomplished before stepping down i'll
share that in about 20 minutes